that's what's featuring y'all period
it's harry styles
[Laughter]
what's going on
lizzo just announced the featured artist
on rumors
and no it's not harry styles
no here's the t it's cardi freaking
b after teasing her upcoming single
rumors on tic tac over the weekend
they say i should watch the edition i'll
post
the grammy winner finally revealed who's
joining her on the track
posting this space-time call between her
and cardi to instagram monday
announcing their collab
good morning mother
that's who it's featuring y'all period
it's harry styles
and if you're confused about the whole
harry mention prior to the big
announcement the 33 year old singer's
comments were
filled with guesses that the song
featured the one direction member
and honestly it wasn't a bad guess since
the two are pals
have performed together before and have
both covered each other's tracks in the
[Music]
past
[Music]
now we know rumors features cardi and we
are here for it good morning
[ __ ]
that's who it's featuring y'all period
lizzo captioned the post quote
grand rising [ __ ] guess who's
hopping on rumors with me
damn this is a big deal lizzo first
hinted at the track
with this post captioned new era
rumors 813 and she shared several
tik-tok videos since then featuring the
song including
this clip singing rumors acapella
[Music]
the highly anticipated song is the jew
singer's first single since she
dropped her album cause i love you back
in 2019.
i mean it takes 10 years to be overnight
success period like
anybody who just pops up you know
definitely laid the groundwork
so you know i was always going to be a
career musician i just didn't know i was
going to be
this yeah i'm going to be the star girl
i didn't know
but can't nobody predict that that's you
know that's in god's hands
and cardi's been wanting to work with
lizzo for a while now
oh yes honey remember her show stopping
music video for [ __ ]
macaroni
well last year during a chat with hot 97
the rapper revealed she wanted lizzo to
make a cameo i really wanted like lizzle
on
on the video because i'm cool with
lizzle and everything like we'd be
sending
uh dms to each other and all that but um
she wasn't in town but i was like oh my
gosh
because i had a whole vision of how i
wanted to see lizzle and everything but
it's like
she was on vacation yeah so something
tells me we have
a lot to look forward to when the music
video for rumors drops
that's who it's featuring y'all period
[Music]
you